can you believe stepbrothers is rotted
next you're gonna tell me is that
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles too
secretive abused is also rotten relax
there's hope
Rotten movies we look by the editors are
brought in to baylin's you can love
writing movies that's right
Rodimus advance presents the rotten
movies we love book written cases for
why you should love those rotting cult
classics 101 rotten films with uplifting
and passionate words for some of your
favorite guilty pleasures that your
friends have been secretly judging you
for such as home alone - wait wait what
really what the [ __ ] the Furious Tokyo
Drift
oh it wasn't about acting it was about
family spread across seven exciting
sections including cult leaders so bad
they're good dude and sequels worth a
second like rocky for that movie
defeated communism you'll also get
quirky and beautiful
Jets critic essays like one from letter
Mountain and a foreword written by the
legendary Paul Feig Tim counselor yeah
this amazing collection can be yours for
the small price of 3 9999 but order
within the next 10 minutes and we'll
give it to you for only twenty three
ninety-nine
that's a savings of 94% thanks Rotten
Tomatoes rotten movies we love order now
[Music]